e aí pessoas como você e eu tenha
percebido mas aí tem muita propaganda
toscano televisão parece não tenho muita
propaganda política na televisão a cada
dia o pessoal fazendo propaganda muito
tem sempre a propaganda tem sempre a
propaganda muito boa adocica do circo
show cá temos que eu acho muito ruim
também é tipo já viu aquela esparadrapo
até agora só tinha um jeito de você
emagrecer es pa es para tráfego
olhando ethos que esse padrão que bota
de esparadrapo na boca é ter uma
propaganda também é muito marcante na
televisão brasileira que é aquela que
faz uma mãe quero fazer algo na casa do
pedrinho esse moleque tem algum problema
não tem como o pessoal eu por exemplo só
acarretará seu gosto de droga eu com
certeza eu vencer que eu passar três
meses dentro da cada três meses em carga
agora moleque na mulher cagar na casa do
outro esse moleque tem algum problema em
propaganda da escola é a cerveja que
desce redondo vai pra mim o que desce
redondo é bom também propaganda aquelas
marcas de xampu não é que ele faz
milagre com o cabelo da mulher e deixa o
cabelo liso deixa os cabelos e do outro
o cabelo parece que vive em cinema toda
hora sabe parece que acaba de verdade aí
quando o cara vai com ela fala assim não
[Música]
há o cara a desgraçada no meio da rua
capelo piano do cabo março vá que o
cabelo ruim cabeça o jeito ó gente não
se propaga com o que mais ajuda né
ele chamou de cara de cada um
você está embaixo achado meu lado né
quem também tem também aquelas
propagandas que o cara parece que
injetou um cano na ver parece que a
maior alegria da vida dele está
anunciando aqueles móveis lá porque fica
tipo sofá vermelho que r$298 próprios
r$290 liquidificador a ser de 25 09 19
reais fico imaginando ficar em casa e
sei lá chegando direto na casa dele
falando sente aqui no meu sofá que caiu
de 298 recopa r$290 é um dia ter um
liquidificador que para fazer o sul
o liquidificador de 27 caiu para 19 já
estava em cima da cama geladeira que foi
de mil reais problemas 999 é só a mãe tu
te pagando muito chato é carro de som e
o campeão do carro de som não é nem é
esse ser um carro de som eles só chegar
na hora que você está fazendo alguma
coisa que não pode fazer barulho era tá
quieto pra ficar assim agora pega a
câmera grava negócio é pacificar os
carros de som ao carro ali está passando
na sua rua pra cá voltar pra cá vovó de
cara inteligente época a senhora no
carro do alho é usuário do [ __ ] aí
eles não satisfeito em baixa e fazer
barulho em sua rua e irritante a caruaru
está passando a rolar meio chato de
divulgação o primeiro que ninguém lhe
uma pessoa está dirigindo carros era só
ver o ódio e quem tá escutando e também
as propagandas muito muito
pinto estenda adocica eu gostei demais
acho que música cerveja uma coisa que
combina embora não goste de ser tem
também a propaganda de jogos beijo que
eu gostava demais porque o amor nasceu
eu acho que combina muito com criança é
musique eu adoro canto até hoje
protestou goiana a cabeleira onde os
sons baby shampoo lá lá lá xuxa oi é um
grande caminho cachê atentado nem
plantão têm também claro nas propagandas
mais show de todos os tempos que é o
paraíba jogando bola com as crianças no
meio da rua não sei se você já viu uma
bola de leite amarelo caminhão pintada
que paraíba passava na rua de todo mundo
que jogavam bola cara a inscrição é
correr atrás das bolas bola pingando
lindo voador inpi vai poder pegar a
bolinha que caiu no chão por lá fora na
porta de todo jeito hoje quem tem uma
bola do paraíba
é um dinheiro 10 mais ou menos desse
tamanho aqui assim amarela que elas
podem ser uma bola de leite sabor
direita tipo dente de leite só que na
dente de leite é porque você vai receber
uma melhor depois então oceano desde
leite nas idêntico permanente que a bola
de leite
infelizmente não existe bola de couro do
paraíba a bola sabe aquelas boas
maneiras sabe chutar fazer a bola pegar
prefeito nakao pra casa pra cá então
leve que é pior que a bola maluca do
bumbum agora vai aparecer um monte de
gente dizendo que tem um bom ano paraíba
e eu sei que é mentira porque não existe
mais um ano para ele que eu tinha o meu
furor de tanto bem que eu fiz com ela eu
sou publicidade show do paraíba não
existe propaganda melhor que a do
paraíba jogando bola para as crianças
que aí as crianças toyota na bola o pai
saía pra ver uma incorrecta na bola e
viu aquele caminhão gigante paraíba
se você não é do nordeste não vai
entender melhor a bola
mas abandonou paraíba tipo procópio daí
sabe aquele pirulito que virava alicoop
colocado falei com um boné há uns tempos
atrás é o quadro vende essa câmera que
não tinha a pagar ela eu tô pagando ela
e eu fiquei desesperado quase rende ela
e aí não tem mais vídeo não tem mais
nada só não vende porque porque me
ofereceram ajuda só que em troca eu
tenho que fazer uma propaganda quem
estava me ajudando eu não sei fazer
propaganda não dá pra fazer propaganda
muito ruim como esparadrapo outro ponto
que também não dá pra fazer propaganda
muito boa como no paraíba quem me ajudou
foi a clínica pinheiro em campineiro
fica em bom jesus do piauí
ali em frente à praça do fórum centro é
claro existem muitos propaganda de
clínica também são que não sabe qual é
confiar porque sem médico é uma coisa
que ter muita responsabilidade
eu por exemplo nunca pensei que um
médico na minha vida eu não tenho
responsabilidade outubro na aula não
assisto alô to num estudo aí pensei o
torcedor mede 5 ipad tornar a aula é
total pelo consultor a doutor fazer
cirurgia evita adotou e do sul nunes vem
aqui fazer a cirurgia eu chego lá lá o
paciente é 1 55
a doença era que foi estudado o dia com
dominá lo e aí a bola correndo barreto
na sala de cirurgia o que é que o
paciente que passei e talita não o está
grande no pescoço não está no meu
pescoço eucatur mina ao estudo avançado
instagram [ __ ] então não dá pra confiar
em qualquer comercial zin de trinca de
falar com o pessoal em todos eles
toca na busca de deus né que você escuta
o mesmo que a tensão do céu que
atrapalha de tem que tá todo mundo ricos
e todo mundo conhece um carro por dia na
promoção do caminhão do faustão a
propaganda é tão bonita que até o cara
na marca passa a sorrir boston samsung e
aí fica por isso mesmo você acredita em
qualquer bobagem se fala então como eu
sei fazer uma propaganda legal demais e
não quero fazer propaganda ruim demais
devem fazer desse jeito o pessoal que me
ajudou foi a clínica pinheiro os dados
estão aqui na descrição do vídeo e
aparecendo aqui no vídeo também porque
eu sou uma pessoa muito legal e editores
editar e colocar imagens aqui barragens
da física pra você é se você gosta nos
caminhos que eu uso nos vídeos que é
essa daqui sou camisa temática do piauí
tem essa daqui o piauí todo desenhado em
gírias daquilo piauí e outras têm eu
topo disse apenas não basta a ficar tem
um monte é nesse site aqui ó
se você quiser comprar sua camisa comprá
la
e aí seja muito legal bonito
interessante no meio da rua com camisas
temáticas piauiense
pensei muito obrigado se assistir esse
vídeo obrigado pela atenção aqui até o
final se você gostou deste vídeo se você
gostou de servir não se esquece de
clicarem gostei aqui porque me ajuda
muito é comenta que no momento aqui nos
comentários escrevendo aqui nos
comentários e quais propagam se acha
mais ridícula quais eu gosto mais
se você não tá institucional clique aqui
e se inscrever é continuamente novo você
vai saber e loja tem muito filho novo
centro aqui está nas redes sociais aqui
é meu instagram é meu twitter e até meu
facebook é só você conseguir lá pra você
que quer ficar por dentro de tudo o que
eu posso e aí sim muito obrigado e valeu
comercial
agora quer mais